we'll return now to our top story this
hour the escalation in violence in yemen
joining us live from sana'a is hussein
al-mukeity a political commentator and
journalist thanks for being with us uh
what is happening uh right now in murray
the coalition says that it's killed
hundreds of houthi fighters over the
past week
i think those claims are false because
they have as well say two days ago they
have killed 200 and three days ago they
say they have killed more than 400 as
they say holy fighters but we see on the
ground uh that yemeni army here and on
sarla
are advancing
toward maribel city i mean they have not
actually do all those
saudi strikes and all this claim of the
this huge amount of uh killing holy
fighter did not stop this show you that
i don't think that the saudi
airstrike
now have any effect and the main reason
of that is because the germany air
defense has actually take out also audi
uh drones uh uh uh uh
which those drones actually the saudi
depend on them to collect information uh
for areas to attack that's why uh they
have liberated in the last two 48 hours
province and now they are advancing
towards south of maryland who's saying
how do the houthis respond to uh
accusations that they are besieging the
local population in mary what help
are they getting from locals in the
area are they supported or do locals not
want them there
to be honest with you they there are
many most of the fighters who are now
advancing towards marriage they are from
mary province this is one of the
strategy that here forces have been
using they mainly try to use fighters
from that area that they are gonna
liberate and this actually send a kind
of a good uh message uh to the people
there and if if all
people there were against uh yemeni army
i don't think that they could advance uh
uh for one meter and but the main reason
now there are
there is a huge uh support now in area
under the control of saudi back forces
the support actually is toward uh some
are forces is because we have you've
seen uh the security uh the bad security
situation in
as an example one dollar in marip it
cost to uh uh one thousand four hundred
yemeni real but in sana one dollar is
six hundred yemeni real and they show
you that the economy there the security
situation has actually collapsed in the
last a few years that's why people in
this area actually
are coming back uh to uh forces and they
are
reaching uh sana and this is one of the
main reason why yemeni forces here in
are advancing in marriage okay many
thanks indeed
uh hussein al mulcati there political
commentator and journalist in sanaa